κάθα το προλαβούμε εννοείται δεν είχαμε καμία ν αφιβολί αντουλάχισ τον όση είμαστα στο στενών
περίγυρον τις τις διοργάνωσης γνωρίζαμε τες τις διαδικασίες και τοπως εξελίσοντα τα πράγματα βέβαιος διαχωρίζοντας
σε δύο έτσι πλώνες ι όλη διοργάνως η διαχωρίζεται σε διοπηλώνες η μεία έχει να
κάνει με την διοργάνωση και ότι προαπετείται για να είμαστεν ετιμηνά υποδιεχτούμε τους αστέρες του
ευρωπαϊκού και παγκόσμιου πάσκε αλλά και όλος όσους αφιλοξενήσουμε και ο άλλος οπιλώ νας ήταν
βεβαίος ή αναβάθμηση και ανακαίνηση τ του κλιστου κυπέδου το οποίο θα φιλοξενήσει το ευρωμάσκες
που δεν είναι άλλον από το σπύρος κυπριανος στη λεμεσό οπόταν δουλεύαμε όλο λ αυτόν
το διάστημα σε δύο παράληλους πιλώνες ο καθένας με τις δικές του ιδιοτεερέτες και τς
γές του δυσκολίες βέβαίος δεν θα ακριβμα στην ότι η πιο δύσκολη έτσι διαδικασία ήταν
οι αναβάθμηση του του κυπεδου που περάσαμε α από πολλά και διάφορα αναβάθμηση του κυπέδουν
όταν πας να διεκδικήσεις μια τέτοια διοργάνως να δεν πρέπει να δούμε και τη υποδομε
σε έχουμε διαδή μι υπως ήρθε ο καιρός να να αυτιάξουμε υποδομές που αρμόζουν σε
μια ευρωπαϊκή χώρα που θέλει να ναλαβάνει τέτοιου ίδους διοργανώσεις θεωρώ ότι με την επιτυχή
αντηδική μας έχει ανοίξει ήδι αυτός όλι διάλογος και έχουν βγή στην επιφάνειαν προβλήματα το
οποία κρίβοντα τα τελευταία χρόνια κάτω από το χαλί γιατί βολευόμασταν να να παίζουμε μόνον
με ατά που είχαμε και να μη διεκδικούμε ήταν έναν πολύ μεγάλον προαπετούμενον κατά τη
διάρκεια τις διαδικασίας τις εκδήλωση είναι διαφέροντας από την πλευρά μας προς την ομοσπουν τις
προς την ευρωπαϊκή νομοσπονδία γιαν για την ανάθεση και ήταν κάτι το οποίον είχαμε μελετήσει
βεβαίως στην πορεία εξελικτικά και τα προβλήματα που ήταν ντόμινο σε σχέση μετος